[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hey,
I'm Mark and I'm here
at the Bootcamps section of
Google Cloud Next, where we've
got thousands of technical
practitioners and developers
here to learn a new skill, or
get Google Cloud Certified.
Attendees can check out
trainings, take hands on labs,
or get assessed for Google
Cloud Certification.
Of course, each lifelong
learning journey
is a unique one.
So let's talk to
some of the folks
who have been Google
Cloud Certified.
THARA SAVIO: I chose to get
Google certified primarily
to have a very good
knowledge on Google Cloud.
Also to have confidence,
especially when
you interact with clients.
Or even within a company when
you want to build a system--
to have that confidence.
JIGAR NAVADIYA: I chose
Google Cloud Certification
to gain the trust of my clients,
that I had the technical skills
to build the best data
pipeline and the architectures
for their business requirements.
GREG LAZARUS: So I
chose to be certified
because there is a real
value for the certification
on the market.
Every company is really
looking for that.
And if you want to
work in the Cloud,
you have to have certifications.
GIOTTO MASAWI: Part
of it was knowing
that the Google Cloud Platform
has been growing exponentially.
I thought this was the best
time to be well aligned
with such an environment
and technology
and get that certification
for Google Cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
the certification process
doesn't stop there.
They're taking their
teachings back with them
to help their own teams start
on their learning journeys.
JIGAR NAVADIYA: From the
certification, right,
I wanted to gain more and more
learning from my fellow Google
Cloud Certified
team and Googlers
to learn more real
world use cases.
GIOTTO MASAWI: So part of
it has been career growth.
On my side, there's been a huge
spike from the clients that
have been reaching out to me.
And I've also worked with
the team-- about four.
My team members and I would
all dedicate a lot of time
to studying and learning
the whole Google Cloud
suite of products that they
have to make sure that we're
prepared for the certification.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hopefully this inspires
you to start your own learning
journey down Google Cloud
certification and seeing
what you can build.
[MUSIC PLAYING]